Humans are social animals.
When we're together,
we get more done faster
by talking face-to-face.
But it's still hard to
get devices that are
near each other to interact.
When they're together,
they should work together.
My name is Andrew Bonner,
and Nearby Messages
is a new proximity API
to let Android and iOS
devices to communicate
across short distances.
Nearby Messages is
perfect for setting up
ad hoc groups,
collaborative sessions,
or sharing resources to
people in a colocated space.
It gives you a
publish-subscribe API
to pass messages between phones
that are within about 100 feet.
To make this work everywhere,
it takes a bit more than magic.
Nearby Messages
makes use of Wi-Fi,
Bluetooth, and even an
ultrasonic modem that uses
the speakers and microphones.
We'll see how you can use that
to restrict the range down
to about five feet.
Let's dive into a fun example,
and see how Google Play Games
built the Nearby players
feature to make it easier
to set up a multiplayer game.
Sending invites by scrolling
through a buddy list,
or typing in user
handles, is a pain.
We'll prepopulate
the game invitations
by using who's
Nearby and in-game.
For creating a
gaming session, we
might want to publish an avatar
image and maybe a gamer handle.
You can serialize this
data however you like.
JSON, protocol buffers,
CSV-- it's up to you.
Pass the serialized bytes to
the constructor of the message
object, call publish,
and we're off.
We also want to see
what players are nearby.
The subscribe call takes
a message listener.
It's on found method
will fire when
the same app on a Nearby
device calls publish.
Within the on found handler,
we pull out the bytes
from the message with get
contents, and modify our UI
to show the players to invite.
It's important to
wait for the user
to take an action before
calling publish or subscribe.
For example, a stateful
button like this
is perfect to let users
know Nearby is active.
Waiting for user
intent is important,
because your app will need
to prompt the user to get
permission to use Nearby.
Nearby introduces a
new runtime permission,
consistent with how Android
M handles permissions.
You don't need to add
anything to your manifest.
And that's important,
because your app
will continue to auto update.
Before calling
publish or subscribe,
you want to check to
see if your app has
permission to use Nearby
with get permission status.
Return status object tells
if you have a permission,
and gives you a way to
ask for it if you don't.
You can see all this in
our examples on GitHub.
The best part is it
all works on iOS.
You can pod install
Nearby messages,
and build a proximity experience
across iOS and Android.
On iOS, when you call
publish, will automatically
prompt the user with a
prepermission dialog to explain
why the app needs microphone.
If your app already has mic
access for other reasons,
we'll trim down the
prepermission text.
Well, let's say you're
publishing something more
sensitive than a gaming avatar.
Maybe an invite token, or
a pointer to a document.
Nearby's default range of
about 100 feet, or 30 meters,
might be too far for your taste.
Let's restrict Nearby to
only using ultrasonic modem,
and get that range down
to about five feet.
The publish call optionally
takes a strategy object.
Just call set distance
type earshot on that
before passing it to publish.
If your use case has natural
send and receive rolls,
you can speed up the
exchange by telling Nearby
which side should broadcast,
and which should scan,
by calling set discovery mode.
So that's how to use the
API at the code level.
There are four tips to keep
in mind when you're designing
your user flow for Nearby.
The first is battery.
Nearby is doing a lot with
the radios and sensors.
An active publish or
subscribe will cause your app
to consume battery at two and a
half to three and a half times
the normal rate.
So you don't want to have
that publish or subscribe
going all the time.
Second, you should
require an explicit action
before invoking
Nearby-- a button
or switch to activate Nearby,
or maybe a special screen.
You can find our
standard icons for these
at developers.google.com/nearby.
Third is to avoid
surprising your users.
The UI should make
clear what data
will be visible to
nearby users of your app
before you call publish.
Also, when Nearby
is active we suggest
indicating this to your
users with an animation.
Finally, exiting
the app or leaving
the flow that
requires Nearby means
you should stop any active
publish or subscribe.
In your activities
on pause method,
call unpublish and unsubscribe.
So that's Nearby messages.
A new way to reduce the friction
of working or playing together
when your users are together.
Visit
developers.google.com/nearby
to get started.
We can't wait to
see what you build.
[MUSIC PLAYING]